Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This piece of work enables us to walk around
in a room with a camera, and create a complete
3D computer model from the video footage.
The technique has a really cool effect where
the 3D model is continuously refined as we
obtain more and more data by walking around
with our camera.
This is a very difficult problem, and a good
solution to this offers a set of cool potential
applications. If we have a 3D model of a scene,
what can we do with it? Well, of course, assign
different materials to them and run a light
simulation program for architectural visualization
applications, animation movies, and so on.
We can also easily scan a lot of different
furnitures and create a useful database out
of them. There are tons of more applications,
but I think these should do for starters.
Normally, if one has to create a 3D model
of a room or a building, the bottom line is
that it requires several days or weeks of
labor. Fortunately, with this technique, we'll
obtain a 3D model in real time and we won't
have to go through these tribulations. However,
I'd like to note that the models are still
by far not perfect, if we are interested in
the many small, intricate details, we have
add them back by hand.
Previous methods were able to achieve similar
results, but they suffer from a number of
different drawbacks, for instance, most of
them don't support traditional consumer cameras
or take minutes to hours to perform the reconstruction.
To produce the results presented in the paper,
an NVIDIA TITAN X video card was used, which
is currently one of the pricier pieces of
equipment for consumers, but not so much for
companies who are typically interested in
these applications. If we take into consideration
the rate at which graphical hardware is improving,
anyone will be able to run this at home in
real time in a few years time.
The comparisons to previous works reveal that
this technique is not only real time, but
the quality of the results is mostly comparable,
and in some cases, it surpasses previous methods.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!